MONDAY JUNE TWENTY NINTH TWENTY
TWENTY IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER.
PLEASE BE ADVISED ON AUDIO AND
VIDEO RECORDING IS BEING MADE
OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS AS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED. ADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THERE.
FLORA GRAYSON A MARKER
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS QUIRK SILVA
HERE RAMOS RIVAS YEAH WICKS WE
HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE A QUORUM
WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA I DO
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE HAVE ADDED
SB SEVEN SEVENTY THREE A
SKINNER BUILT OVER FOR A LYSIS
BEEN VETTED WITH STAFF OF
BEFORE FOR DOING THAT IS OUR
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
MOVE I'M IS CAREER SECULAR BY
MR RIVAS OF BETTER SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY HI
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM CARILLO
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA AYE
GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE AYE
KAMLAGER MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MATHIS AYE AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I RAMOS RIVAS RIVAS
I'D MOTION PASSES- THAT MOTIONS
PASSED- COLORS I WANT TO SAY
THAT. IN REFERRING. THE HILL
BILL TO THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
THE PRECEDENT FOR THAT- UNDER
PRIOR RULES CHAIRS. THESE TYPES
OF BILLS HAVE BEEN SINGLE
REFERRED TED LIU DID IN HIS
TIME IT SUPPORTSGOOD
DELIBERATION I THINK ON BEHALF
OF OUR PROCESS I AM LOOKING FOR
IS RULES CHAIR. TO CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT BILLS INDIVIDUALLY ON
THEIR SUBJECT MATTER AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR BEFORE PANELS
WHETHER PROS AND CONS AND THEIR
SUBS THE PUBLIC POLICY
IMPLICATIONS WILL BE WELL THAT
IT. SO THAT'S KIND OF A
DIRECTION THAT WE'VE DONE TODAY
THIS OF COURSE IS PRECIPITATED
IN PART BY COVE ID. WHICH HAS
IMPORT RESPIRATORY IMPLICATIONS
THAT BILL WILL SPEAK TO THAT IT
IS ALSO PRECIPITATED. BY AS A
CONSEQUENCE A COVERT I'VE BEEN
DOING SINGLE REFERRALS AND HAVE
BEEN CAREFUL TO WORK WITH OTHER
COMMITTEES TO MAKE SURE THAT IF
THE CHAIR HAD A PERSPECTIVE
WANNA BROUGHT TO BEAR THAT THEY
COULD COORDINATE. WITH THE-
MEGAN ARE FOR ALL. BUT I
DEFINITELY FEEL THAT. I INTEND
TO KIND OF MOVE THIS THE
DIRECTION OF. SUPPORTING
DELIBERATION BY OUR BODY WHICH
IS WHAT THE PUBLIC LOOKS FOR
AND WITH THAT OF THIS RULES
PROCEDURE AND I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.